[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute geht's ein superschnelles und mega
leckeres rezept ich werde einen betonen
mandl kuchenbacken ganz ohne mehl da ist
super saftig die zutaten habe ich
persönlich immer da vielleicht habt ihr
ja auch gerade da und backt diesen
kuchen einfach ganz schnell nach und
genießt ihn einfach nur noch denn es
wirklich der hammer
das ganze habe ich auch noch in
schokoladen variante gemacht und ich
persönlich kann mich nicht entscheiden
was besser ist das könnt ihr dann
entscheiden also heute gibt es die
zitronen man den drohnen wandel kuchen
ich habe ich die zutaten ich brauche
dafür vier eiweiß 120 gramm zucker eine
prise salz 4 etwas vanille extra 90
gramm butter 220 gramm mandeln einen
halben teelöffel backpulver eine zitrone
und 70 gramm gehobelte mandeln die
zitrone ist bio und ungespritzt das
heißt ich kann die schale verwenden und
aber auch den saft okay das erste was
ich machen werde ist da im schnee
ich werde also eiweiß in der saubere
fettfreie schüssel geben mit etwas salz
weil es die eiweißstoffe schneller
zerstört und kurz schreibt schlagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und sobald der schnee fast steif ist
kommt jetzt hier die hälfte des zuckers
dazu einfach nach und nach dazu geben
zur flucht der schnee licht und lässt
sich auch gleich besser unterheben und
dann einfach noch mal weitere
[Musik]
perfekt fahren da muss jetzt nicht ganz
stark sein
so passt perfekt als nächstes ist aus
einer großen schüssel als nächstes kann
ich jetzt hier in der zweiten schlüssel
die eigelbe den restlichen zucker und
etwas waren den extrakt verrühren
auch richtig schön schaumig rühren
[Musik]
wie drüben kann ich schon mal die butter
schmelzen
[Musik]
so sieht die macher jetzt aus weiß
cremig jetzt gehe ich hier rüber und
kann nämlich die mandeln direkt hier
rein zerkleinern
als ich habe jetzt hier geschenke
mandeln damit der kuchen auch schön hell
bleibt ihr könnt aber natürlich auch
mandel mit schale nehmen und auch schon
gemahlenem anzunehmen
ich habe aber immer nur ganz nach
interner sie selber
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt der abrieb der zitrone
rein mit den ganzen abrieb denn ich will
das ist wirklich schön nach der proa
schmeckt jetzt auch noch den saft dazu
geben
das ganze könnt ihr auch gerne abwandeln
und mit einer orange machen zum beispiel
dann habt ihr einen mann den orangen
kuchen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich hier noch die flüssige
butter und kann das jetzt auch schön
einrühren
[Musik]
das backpulver nicht vergessen hätte ich
fast vergessen das wollte ich eigentlich
mit den mandeln nämlich dazu geben aber
ist nicht schlimm
und jetzt habe ich einfach nur noch den
schnee runter wie gesagt ist er so ein
bisschen schmutzig nicht ganz steif
[Musik]
perfekt und hier könnt ihr stadt
gemahlenen mandeln auch kokosraspeln
nehmen oder haselnüsse bei haselnüsse
finde ich jetzt nicht so gut zur zitrone
passen ihr könnt auch mehr nehmen wenn
ihr keine mandeln habt aber das soll
erst einmal frei achim freyer gucken
sein offizier meine backform bereits
berichtet und zwar nämlich einen
tortenring gehen habe ich auch 24 cm
durchmesser eingestellt und ich schlafe
jetzt noch ein damit einfach nichts
ausläuft als doch ein recht flüssig ist
und so kann ich den teil jetzt hier rein
füllen
hier schön glatt streichen und einfach
noch mit den mandeln bestreuen und dann
kann er in den backofen wird gebacken so
durch ist und danach probieren wir ihnen
also echt zuvor schnell und einfach
[Musik]
der kuchen ist faktisch ich habe ihn
jetzt auch gerade mit glitzer schnee
bestreut und er ist auch abgekühlt und
guckte mal wie schön der aussieht schön
flach gebacken kein huggel
sarah holt jetzt gerade schon einen
teller und eine gabel zum probieren sie
in der super league sehr intim 17 29h
zwölf jahre älter als du wir sind beide
sitzen können wir uns auf 18 einigen wir
zumindest auto fahren dürfen nicht
alleine autofahren ja ohne papa oder
mama
hmm ja schon ne mail
hast du schon statt medien handeln ja
schmeckt man aber gar nicht finde ich
auch mega saftig bleibt auch mehrere
tages absicht mich erinnert der
tatsächlich geschmacklich bisschen an
grieß kuchen weil die konsistenz so und
es gibt im türkischen einen keks kuchen
und dann den erinnert da muss aber echt
voll lecker und ich wünsche mir echt und
nicht süß nicht so süß
ich weiß ja nebel sieht man nicht weil
der kuchen davor steht er ist sehr weich
wollte ich auch mal was zeugen der jahre
haben zeigt mir schön richtig schön den
kurven
kannst du das noch mal zeigen den ganzen
stadt ist das zu nehmen danke also wenn
ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
probiert mal aus in meine app steht auch
noch mal um danach auf meinem blog könnt
das gerne nachlesen
ich weiß nicht was ich noch sagen so ist
halt super einfach schnell gemacht und
ohne mehl mit dem freund definitiv
glutenfrei für alle die könnte genau und
wenn ihr jetzt fragt was könnt ihr stadt
mandeln eben wie gesagt habe müsse
kokosraspeln oder wenn ihr mir da habt
ihr könnt auch gerne mehr nehmen aber
dann ist es halt ein normaler verdruckst
also wahrscheinlich da sind dahinter
also viel spaß beim nachhaken
bis zum nächsten
denn
[Musik]
klatscht die mütze von samira sie sagt
dann auch immer aus wie seine
peruanische panflötenspielerin los
kleinen knick machen ob schatz hast du
alles alleine getragen
super viel spaß beim picknick